all right to the boat pad I'm gonna mow
flats like to the wooden create itself
right thanks Nikki still Catalina peace
what music okay that we want to
civilians I am trying to convey that
Muslim women belong in hip-hop though it
is a male-dominated arena we definitely
are here we're knowledgeable we have
rhymes we have soul and we have
something to say powerful group of must
look sisters coming together to share
our experiences with not only being
involved in the hip-hop community and
like the hip hop culture but also being
Muslim we have a lot of love and care
for each other and this is like
something for us to like uplift each
other
image of a woman when people think about
that in fact they think video vixen they
think submissive they think less than
and it's really difficult sometimes to
stand up and rise above that the muffins
he addressed take off with forgiveness
it's his love this event is the first of
its kind in California I think it's
necessary because hip-hop has a stigma
and the Muslim community and especially
with sisters going up there and let's
Benton Ryan's and Eric's wearing a hijab
but though we've been facing all of
these challenges we got a great turnout
today and so noticing that people are
becoming more open to it and sort of
open to understanding our stories and
our struggles that we want to share with
the world